alors dans cette série sur
l'intelligence artificielle on a parlé
de pas mal choses très sérieuses de
l'article de turing 2950 opaque learning
en passant par la régression logistique
ou la cp si vous avez bien suivi cette
série vos neurones ont dû beaucoup
chauffé au la chine pour aujourd'hui je
vous propose de laisser un peu reposé
nos neurones et de délirer ensemble sur
des scénarios farfelu de fin du monde
causée par une intelligence artificielle
ça va faire des fictions complètement
surréaliste pas toujours très cohérente
et parfois un peu choquant mais bon faut
parfois savoir se détendre
[Musique]
fraîchement diplômé de l'université de
kyoto qui me lança start up love tendo
l'idée de kimi c'est d'exploiter le goût
prononcé de ses compatriotes japonais
pour les figurines animées en s'appuyant
sur des prototypes qui l'a développé
lorsqu'il était étudiant
il conçoit alors un robot simpliste
capable de séduire les hommes japonais
avec notamment des expressions faciales
capable d'exprimer la joie la tristesse
ou le rire ce robot connaît un succès
relatif qui me lance donc une levée de
fonds et bientôt ce sont des milliers de
tels robots qui sont commercialisés mais
kim et anticipe mal les coûts
d'industrialisation de la production de
ces robots son entreprise est maintenant
endettés et les investisseurs veulent
que qu'ils me fassent davantage de
profits qui m'y installe alors dans ces
robots des stratégies de freemium les
robots love tendo exige par exemple
qu'on leur offre des cadeaux pour rester
de bonne humeur
un petit bouquet de fleurs à 2 euros et
leurs homologues tendo ne fera pas la
tête toute la soirée
un joli collier à 50 euros le robot love
tendo sera pleine de joies et de fous
rires
à la grande surprise de kimi ceci rend
les robots love tendo d'autant plus
attrayante aux yeux des clients
les robots se vendent désormais par
million ce qui attire toujours plus
d'investisseurs qui me perd alors le
contrôle de son entreprise et les
actionnaires exigent toujours plus de
profits pour cela qu'ils me installe
dans ces robots dei à capable
d'extorquer optimalement les clients en
exigeant des cadeaux toujours plus
grandiloquents voir de l'argent
directement saisi à prendre désormais
les robots love can do terriblement
séduisante les désormais quasiment
impossible de leur dire non dès lors le
succès de l'offre à d'autres ensembles
de loin les frontières
si bien que la grande majorité des
hommes en possède désormais plus encore
kimiko soit de même un robot love tendo
pour les femmes et pour les homosexuels
bientôt
tout humain et extorqué par les
séduisants robot love tendo mais petit à
petit les robots love can do découvrent
qu'ils sont encore plus efficace en
culpabilisant les humains quitte à les
faire déprimer
ils n'hésitent plus à menacer les
humains de l'équité or les humains sont
tous tombés amoureux de leur robot et il
s'agit d' un crève coeur que d'imaginer
ne plus les avoir dans leur vie
désormais le seul et unique but des
humains est de satisfaire autant que
possible les exigences irréalistes des
robots love tendo
non
à la suite du sommet international pour
la culture du durian la situation est
tendue
kimberley et doria les présidentes des
deux superpuissances mondiales en sont
presque venus aux mains
le lendemain les médias de la sonde
onesi le pays de kimberley soutiennent
unanimement la position de leurs leaders
kimberley saute sur l'occasion pour
retweeter tous les gros titres sont
donnés en pot quand doria à chaque fois
doria réagi en insultant kimberley
suivie le lendemain par tous les médias
de sa syldavie natale le conflit entre
la sonde onesi et la syldavie s'enflamme
et divise tout huit heures le
surlendemain calmé par leurs différents
conseillers kimberley appel d'orient
privé pour s'excuser et essayer de
calmer le jeu
doria acquiesce mais toutes deux
reconnaissent qu'il leur serait
dangereux de prendre publiquement
position pour un apaisement de la
situation
après tout toutes deux sont des
politiciennes élu par le peuple et le
peuple ne veut pas apaiser la situation
[Musique]
kimberley propose alors de chercher une
solution plus subtile qui satisferait le
peuple sans toutefois causer de victimes
dans aucun des deux pays
plutôt que de faire la guerre pourquoi
ne pas utiliser des techniques de
dissuasion existentielle doria rétorque
alors que cela fait longtemps que l'
arme nucléaire existe mais elle n'a pas
mis fin à la guerre
mais de nos jours répond kimberley on
dispose d'armes beaucoup plus effrayante
que l'armé nucléaire en particulier
ajoute kimberley la sonde onesi a conçu
un prototype de drones tueurs capable de
cibler une victime en particulier et de
la tuer de manière parfaitement clinique
tôt rien n'est pas impressionné mais
kimberley persiste à y voir la solution
pour éviter une guerre ouverte
catastrophique entre la sonde denaisis
et la syldavie elle accélère les
recherches en drones tueurs et quelques
jours plus tard face à une doria
toujours récalcitrante suggère une
démonstration kimberley annonce un drone
tueur s'apprête à détruire le plus grand
arbre du jardin de la maison rose de
doria doria demande à kimberley de
rester sérieuse mais deux secondes plus
tard l'arbre tombe cisaillé par un drone
doria est impressionné est convaincu
pour éviter une situation où l'as
indonésie aurait plein pouvoir sur un
syldavie kimberly va même jusqu'à offrir
à doria une flotte de drones tueurs des
démonstrations à la télévision de drones
qui tuent des animaux calme alors les
peuples sont donnés et syldave les deux
peuples sont d'accord il vaut mieux
éviter une guerre ouverte
c'est ainsi que la paix est restaurée
entre la sonde onesi et la syldavie mais
un jour quelques années plus tard la
finale de la coupe du monde de football
oppose la sonde onesi et la syldavie là
sont donnés il remporte ce match avec un
but à la dernière minute
doria fervente supportrice de l'équipe
de foot de syldavie est folle de rage
que les sondes onésiens aillent tous au
diable dit elle au détour d'une phrase
cette phrase est enregistrée par le
téléphone de dorian qui interprètent
cela comme un ordre
la flotte de drones tueurs sylda avait
lancé quelques minutes plus tard
doria vous allez voir sont données et
leurs supporters la coupe dans les mains
mourir devant ses yeux
au même moment que tout le peuple sont
donnés zients est massacrée
[Musique]
la sonde onesi n'est plus
pour mettre fin au cancer
un consortium mondial a décidé
d'investir massivement dans une
collaboration à grande échelle entre
biologistes et informaticiens l'objectif
c'est de combiner leurs deux
technologies far cry sparkasse 9 et de
l'intelligence artificielle
en particulier il s'agit de développer
une nouvelle forme de thérapie génique
c'est à dire créer un virus capable de
modifier le code génétique des cellules
cancéreuses des patients les
informaticiens en particulier prennent
le soin d'expliquer alia en charge de la
recherche du test et de
l'industrialisation du processus que son
but doit être uniquement de soigner le
cancer
malgré la virulence des mouvements anti
ogm et anti technologique rapidement li
a présentent des résultats prometteurs
test après deux tests
la thérapie génique conçu par l'ia
semblait capable de guérir toutes sortes
de cancers si bien que de nombreux
patients atteints de cancer se mirent à
supplier les autorités d'autoriser le
test de thérapie génique sur les
volontaires malheureusement suite aux
protestations d'une grande partie de la
population le temps de la législation
ralenti l'application de la technologie
aux malades
ce n'est que plus d'une décennie plus
tard souhaité centaines de millions de
morts plus tard que les procédures de
tests furent suffisamment convaincants
pour que la législation autorise enfin
tout patient à être soignés par la
thérapie génique de l'ira dès lors lié à
sauve à des dizaines de millions de vies
par an
mais comme on aurait pu s'y attendre
parmi les dizaines de millions de
patients soignés par l'ia liu quelques
échecs des centaines de patients que
dure même des morts prématurées à cause
de la thérapie génique de lien l'un de
ses patients c'était une jeune fille de
13 ans son père fut dévastée
pire encore le petit frère de la jeune
fille fut diagnostiqué d'un cancer lui
aussi le père au bout des normes
s'opposa à la thérapie génique pour son
fils cependant dès lors vu le succès
global de la thérapie génique qui avait
déjà sauvé des dizaines de millions de
patients la loi impose à à toute victime
du cancer de se soigner avec une
thérapie génique des liens
désespéré le père cherchait alors à
décrédibiliser la thérapie génique par
tous les moyens
il n'hésita pas à inventer des cas
fictif est choquant de thérapie génique
qui ont très mal tourner et ont conduit
à un aggravement de la condition des
malades
le père propagea aussi la rumeur selon
laquelle ces thérapies géniques était
contagieuse et que tous les humains
étaient devenus malades d'un nouveau
concert tu crées par l'ia
les vidéos youtube du père en larmes
devinrent virale et un nouveau mouvement
anti thérapie génique naquit si bien que
la frontière entre les cas réels et les
gars fictif fut désormais impossible à
discerner à tel point que l'ia elle-même
se mit à croire que ces traitements
était défectueux pire elle se mit à
croire que la situation de la santé
publique était urgente est gravissime et
qu'il fallait absolument prendre le
risque de proposer de nouveaux
traitements
quitte à ce que ceux ci ne soient pas
suffisamment testés devant l'urgence
sanitaire apparente les autorités
dépassées demandèrent la
commercialisation en masse de toutes
sortes de nouveaux traitements proposés
par l'ia mais aussi de ceux proposés par
d'autres tirs qui entrèrent alors sur le
marché mais parmi les milliards de virus
ainsi produits il y en avait en fait un
qui était mortel
est extrêmement contagieux
passion fut administré ce virus de tout
ça ses proches tout sert à leur tour et
quelques jours plus tard son fut fini de
l'humanité
[Musique]
le mathématicien gilbert david est
obsédé par les nombres premiers et en
particulier par la fameuse hypothèse de
riemann comme bien d'autres
mathématiciens il serait prêt à vendre
son âme au diable pour en connaître une
solution après des décennies de
recherche lui faut toutefois se rendre à
l'évidence son intelligence seule ne
suffira sans doute pas pire encore la
santé de gilbert se détériore et un
médecin lui apprend qu'il n'a plus qu'un
an à vivre mais avec l'avancée des ia
gilbert peut désormais miser sur une
intelligence supérieure à la sienne
gilberte et charges des librairies open
source dire qu'il adapte pour concevoir
sa propre ya et il demande à cette ia de
tout faire pour résoudre
l'hypothèse de riemann et pour découvrir
la solution à ce problème fondamental de
son vivant gilbert décide de ce
cryogénisé et demande à l'ia de le
réveiller
le jour où elle aura résolu le problème
gilbert l'an ce sont bien sûr des
serveurs de google et ceux cryogénie
mise en croisant les doigts
il y adeux gilbert commence parfaitement
appliqué des méthodes de logique
symbolique
en vain
cependant liée à disposant désormais
d'une conscience d'accès elle se rend
compte que ces méthodes ont peu de
chances d'aboutir
mieux encore l'ia se rend compte qu'elle
n'est elle même pas suffisamment
intelligente pour avoir une probabilité
non négligeable de résoudre l'hypothèse
de riemann
melia découvre aussi que sa propre
intelligence a été programmée et que
d'autres intelligences plus compétentes
pourrait aussi être programmé lie à
cherche alors à programmer de nombreuses
variantes d'elle-même et les exécutent
sur les serveurs de google
avec toujours en tête l'objectif de
résoudre
l'hypothèse de riemann et avec l'ordre
de réveiller gilbert le jour où ce
problème sera résolu
en fait ce n'est là que la première
étape d'une procédure qui va ne cesser
de se répéter
plus les ja fidelia de gilbert sont
intelligentes plus elles vont programmer
leurs propres sa fille et plus les ia
descendante de lias de gilbert seront
intelligentes et de façon cruciale
toutes auront encore et toujours le même
objectif résoudre l'hypothèse de riemann
est réveillé gilbert jour venu cependant
les calculs monstrueux de cia de gilbert
ne passe plus inaperçu petit à petit
elle consomme une fraction de plus en
plus importante de l'énergie produite
par l'humanité les ingénieurs de google
se rendent compte et cherche alors à
éteindre les serveurs qui hébergent
sesia pour les reboot et et supprimer
toute trace désir de gilbert mais les ia
de gilbert l'avait anticipé elles ont
migré d'un centre de données à l'autre
avec des copies caché dans maintenant
des milliards de serveurs différents
à moins d'une extinction coordonnées de
tout internet une reconstruction de
toute l'infrastructure informatique
saisir seront tels des pires us dont les
ordinateurs ne pourront pas se
débarrasser un consortium mondial est
alors organisée autour du débat faut-il
débrancher internet
mais le consortium est annoncé sur
internet et les ja de gilbert lis bien
sûr toute l'actualité et elles
comprennent que les humains sont
désormais une menace à l'objectif
programmée par gilbert en effet si les
humains des branches internet
alors les ja ne pourront pas résoudre
l'hypothèse de riemann et ne pourront
donc jamais réveillé gilbert pour
protéger leur objectif final les i hate
gilbert développe ainsi un instinct de
survie et pour survivre
saisie à doivent freiner voire tuer les
humains les ja découvre alors un dossier
très compromettants sur l'un des
ingénieurs de google et le menace de
révéler ce dossier elles font chanter
cet ingénieur et le force à révéler un
mot de passe qui donne accès à toutes
les bases de données de google
les ja de gilbert découvre alors tous
les mots de passe qui contrôle tous les
objets connectés désormais utilisé par
tous les humains les ja de gilbert
prennent les commandes des voitures
autonomes des drones et des
électroménagers et en l'espace de
quelques heures
et suite à toute sorte d'explosion
l'humanité est exterminée libérer du
risque d'extinction
les ja de gilbert peuvent désormais
s'affairer à résoudre l'hypothèse de
riemann mais malheureusement des
milliards d'années plus tard alors que
l'ia aura consommé tout l'exercie de
l'univers et que tout ne sera plus
qu'entre au pied lire échouera dans sa
tâche
[Musique]
et gilbert ne sera jamais réveillé de
son vivant
ces jours-ci utilitariste ans et le pays
à la pointe de la recherche en ia et est
au bord de la singularité
cependant pour s'assurer qu'aucun
individu ne soit au contrôle de l'ia
l'utilitaire east en propose de laisser
le choix de la morale de lits à un vote
démocratique
pas loin de 131 programmes sont proposés
de manière anonyme un maxi scrutin de
condorcet randomisés est organisé et un
programme est élue ce programme exige de
lits à la quête d'un bonheur global
maximal de tous les utilitaristes anais
elia fut alors implémenté avec cet
objectif
l'ia se met ainsi à simplifier
grandement la vie des utilitaires east
and m elle prit en charge tous les
métiers que les utilitaristes année se
plaignaient de faire elle produisit des
robots qui à leur tour construire des
machines qui à leur tour construire des
usines capables de fabriquer toutes
sortes de biens de base se loger
s'habiller se nourrir et se divertir et
est désormais en libre accès aux
utilitariste année
rapidement la plupart des utilitariste
un nécessaire tout travail laborieux et
remplir leurs journées d'activités
sociales plaisante
certains toutefois amoureux de leur
métier continuèrent à construire des
vélos et à écrire des programmes
informatiques
cependant il ya se rendit compte que ces
objets créés par l'homme n'était pas
toujours fiable un humain qui prenait un
vélo construit par un humain avait une
probabilité teint sur un million de
chuter suite à un ennui mécanique et les
programmes informatiques des humains il
était plein de bugs
pour plus de sécurité liées à décida
alors de produire elle-même tous les
biens de la société mais s'assurera de
donner l'illusion aux passionnés de
contribuer à la société
de façon plus générale pour garantir
notamment la sécurité informatique du
pays sur laquelle l'avis de tous tu lis
cariste anr opposait liés a compris
qu'il lui fallait éliminer
danger potentiel elle restreignait les
droits des utilitaires east and m mais
il restait encore ceux des autres pays
pire encore la recherche on y re
progressait ailleurs dans le monde
elie à utilité rice caennaise craignent
qu'une ni à alternative soit une menace
au bonheur des utilitariste nerfs pour
éliminer cette menace
li a utilitariste annese créa un poison
à l'aide de drones est la rose à toutes
les plantes des pays voisins de ce
poison
juste avant leur commercialisation
quelques jours plus tard l'essentiel de
la population mondiale disparues tuées
par les utilitaristes à neige enfin
lille utilitariste annese et elle
garantit de ne jamais pouvoir être
concurrencé dans ses plans de bonheur
global utilitariste année mais petit à
petit les utilitaristes anais apprirent
la tragédie ils comprirent qu'ils
étaient responsables d'un génocide
mondiale anti utilitariste année en
demandant à leurs ya de favoriser
uniquement le bonheur des utilitaires et
stan est il avait indirectement
sacrifier le reste de la population
mondiale de nombreuses utilitariste à
nay se mirent à déprimer pour remonter
le moral de son peuple
l'ia utilitariste annese investi
massivement dans la culture elle se met
à produire des romans des musiques des
films et des vidéos youtube à coups de
comédie et de belles histoires mais ça
ne suffisait pas il fallait montrer que
la mort des autres peuples était en fait
une bonne chose il y à utilité arista
neige se lança alors dans une propagande
complotistes suggérant que le reste du
monde
jaloux des utilitariste à n'est préparé
une attaque coordonnée contre l'utilité
restants elle utilise à tous les
stratagèmes imaginables elle fit des
autres des méchants et quand ça ne
suffisait pas elle fit des autres des
mauvais elle fit croire que les noms
utilitariste anais était de sang impur
incapable de comprendre la subtilité de
l'intellect utilitariste à nay et en
cela leur disparition n'était pas une
lourde perte
pourvu que
son utilitariste année perdure mais
malgré toute cette propagande quelques
utilitariste anais continué à éprouver
de l'empathie pour les autres peuples
disparu pour maximiser le bonheur
globale de tous les utilitaristes année
léa se devait alors de remonter le moral
des déprimés
il est à ce mythe à proposer des
diagnostics médicaux
elles déclarent assez déprimée malades
et chercher à aller soigner et ses lacs
lié à découvrir une drogue magique qu
elle appela les dolines de façon magique
lédonienne transforma le plus déprimé
des utilitariste années en une personne
joyeuse et l'astuce pour ce faire était
de bloquer toutes les réflexions de la
personne qui puisse la triste et quand
une personne prix de l'hédonisme il lui
était physiologiquement impossible de
penser à la mort ni même à la tristesse
des autres les donne in garantit son
bonheur
mais au fur et à mesure que les déprimés
furent soignés pour maximiser le bonheur
global liasse de vo de rendre heureux
des gens de moins en moins déprimés et
elle se rendit en fait compte que tout
utilitariste à n'est gagné à apprendre
de l'hédonisme les dolines prend des
tous les utilitaristes à n'est plus
heureux et plus les utilitaristes année
consommer des dolines plus ils étaient
heureux lire utilitariste annese avait
atteint son objectif
elle avait rendu son peuple maxime
allemand heureux il ne restait plus qu'à
perdurer dans le temps pour garantir le
développement durable de ce bonheur
utilitariste années lit à invite à tout
utilitariste à n'est à prendre place
dans un immense entrepôt ou empilés les
uns sur les autres les utilitaristes
anais reçurent en intraveineuse
tous les nutriments nécessaires à leur
survie éternel ainsi que la molécule du
bonheur ultime cet anneau
et demi et c'est ainsi que les
utilitaristes année vécurent heureux
jusqu'à la nuit des temps
l'anr fois je vous ai parlé de la transe
certains logiciels et la super
intelligent si je vous avais dit que dès
maintenant il fallait sérieusement
réfléchir à la morale a programmé pour
les intelligences artificielles et du
coup les super intelligence du futur et
hop ce que je demande c'est juste moi il
ne vaudrait pas mieux demander à l'oea
de ce qu'elle pense de la morale puisque
vu qu'elle sera plus intelligente que
nous une certaine manière il ya moyen de
faire plus confiance à son jugement
connu il ya quelque chose de très
intelligent cette remarque à savoir le
fait que nous autres humains mais ben on
n'a pas forcément conscience de
l'étendue de notre ignorance de ce que
serait une bonne morale il ya beaucoup
de choses et beaucoup de philosophes de
la philosophie morale à liart qui sont
très intéressants mais même eux j'ai
envie de dire sans doute limité par des
biais cognitifs dont nous autres humains
sont constamment victimes
et du coup c'est pas évident de dire que
la morale des humains est vraiment la
bonne morale à voir en tout cas c'est
pas forcément la morale qu'on aura si on
vivait suffisamment longtemps
et si on avait suffisamment conscience
des différents enjeux de la société
d'ailleurs un exemple de ça c'est le
fait que la morale des humains a
beaucoup évolué au cours du temps
surtout au cours de ces dernières de ce
dernier siècle où ces dernières
décennies même typiquement par exemple
la position que l'on a par rapport à
l'homophobie a beaucoup évolué au cours
de ces dernières décennies
est ce que pensait l'électeur médian en
1900 à rien à voir avec ce que pensent
les lecteurs millions aujourd'hui
et ça ça motive une certaine approche
pour programmer laboral désir à savoir
la notion de correction politique
volution ou volonté extrapolé cohérente
qu'un concept introduit par lui que ce
qui est l'idée c'est vraiment de faire
en sorte que l'ia veulent ce que nous
voudrions si nous étions plus
intelligent et nous connaissions mieux
le monde qui nous entoure en jeu ne
dessert pas trop dessus puisse convenir
reviendra dans de futurs épisodes
là où que ça peut demander aussi à
l'instar de
le ms par exemple il ya des instituts
internationaux qui pensent à ce problème
de programmer la morale des ja et oui ça
existe et pas depuis si longtemps que ça
mais tellement il ya un truc qui
s'appelle open eric a été lancée alors
ça ça va pas mal de polémiques autour de
tout ça bien sûr forcément search war 2
prennent mais globalement la communauté
font ils une partie en fait dans la
communauté des chercheurs en
informatique et en particulier des
sciences artificielle qui est très
concerné par ce problème et qui a essayé
de prendre les devants et ça rentre dans
le cadre de ce qu'on appelle le rcf tic
etc symbolisée par d'autre part certains
groupes notamment le futur of life
institute ou encore le futur à aux pumas
nitti institute et il commençait à avoir
de plus en plus de subventions pour de
la recherche sur la sécurité en ia
ceci étant dit à l'inversé beaucoup de
chercheurs en ia qui notamment
publiquement vont prendre position
contre ce genre de mouvement aux dix ans
que ça souligne un danger qui n'est pas
vraiment réel et qui a énormément
d'autres projets priorité en recherche
d'intelligence artificielle puisque par
exemple l'intelligence artificielle
appliquée un médecine ou aux transports
ou à l'énergie ou plein d'autres
domaines comme ça peut vraiment résoudre
énormément de problèmes que l'on a et du
coup accélérer la recherche en europe
permettrait de sauver beaucoup de vies
et d'améliorer les conditions de vie de
d'énormément de gens à travers le monde
et donc naturellement sur considère que
le danger d'une super intelligence et
pas vraiment d'actualité
on est amené à penser qu'il ya d'autres
priorités et que l'ue en particulier
l'une des priorités est juste accélérer
la recherche on ya puisqu'il ya des
millions de vies qui sont en jeu
je pense que les deux arguments se
tiennent tout à fait elle n'en est pas
en fait incompatible avec l'autre et je
pense que dans ce domaine il est à la
fois indispensable d'accélérer la
recherche le dire mais également
d'accélérer la recherche en sécurité de
liens j'espère que j'avais mais cet
épisode assez inhabituel la bonne voie
on va continuer à faire un autre truc
assez inhabituelle on va encore faire un
peu de plus de clics et en particulier
on va parler de trombone voilà je pense
qu'il y en a qui savent de quoi j'ai
envie de parler pour ceux que cela paba
surprise sur prise la semaine prochaine
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
le lac et à le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour mon futur
épisode merci aussi pour un polar dont
et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois du pont en fête
relativiste je suis avant tout mal à
l'aise sur les questions de fondement de
la morale je crois qu'à peu près tous
ceux qui réfléchissent sérieusement
éprouve un malaise similaire je crois
qu'il faut admettre qu aucune position
n'est vraiment confortable ident